Beyonce came the rest of us me slowly
passing away just completely she like
you're like yeah yeah I mean it was like
an alien yes and I'm like sorry that's
not another example where I really
wanted to know she was there cuz I
looking in the audience and you see just
like the shape of her weave yeah it's
like if I had spotted that I think I
would have just passed out so I was
happy to know exactly what she was gonna
be and that she was we're so different I
would never want to know have you ever
freaked out on anyone Tyler like whoa
well know that we mentioning Beyonce she
was at my party recently one person just
one person that was Nelson Mandela yeah
I got a chance to sit down and talk to
him so not too up you're so nice when
Oprah does therefore you know it's bad
though when I'm talking to friends and I
start hearing myself say things and
they're like let me not at all but it
just seems like it it's like yeah you
know just you know it ain't normal
yeah I was talking to the lady works at
the bank know Obama discover I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this